do you follow the miami dolphins you
follow football at all all right well
you don't even know who he is but
there's a nfl running back he used to be
called well it used to be in the
antibodies called his ricky williams
okay
former nfl star ricky williams takes his
wife's last name to promote balance in
relationship quote unquote it felt
really meaningful so basically nfl
running back ricky moments revealed that
he officially changed his last name to
me
he said that they made the name change
after a year and a half
of his having his uh being his wife of
the for his
his wife had his last name for the last
five years he said he wanted to create
more balance in his marriage and that
was one of the main reasons for changing
his name he says quote unquote my wife
is an attorney she can handle herself
but i'm the faintest one i started to
think of ways to create more balance in
our relationship and i find more meaning
in the name miron than in my last name
williams would you ever take your wife's
last name you're the orangutan
uh
not today and and i didn't ask her to do
it it's a romantic idea i i believe
as animals women and men female and male
we are we tend to be possessive
possessiveness it's not an attractive
idea i call her mia so he's like mine
but i know she's not she's not mine if i
think she's mine i'm gonna start stop
working for a relationship
so
it's a beautiful idea i think it's a
marketing idea i think it's something
it's a tattoo a branded tattoo that he
wants to do for her
to to promote a beautiful idea
but uh i don't know i imagine the red
pill intellect are gonna be like no man
men always need to the last name and
then we need to care because tradition
that's your legacy with legacy we we
tend to betray listen to this idea tell
me if it's true
we're all
traditional ins in in by
uh see exactly we are all traditional
and progressive in whatever suits us
so we want to be traditional in some
ideas like men need to do this but we
all carry the phone we all have new
phones new evolution so we're all
dependent on how it how we how depending
on how it affects you you're going to be
more traditional or not you're going to
pick yours
everyone is progressive and everyone is
traditional would you be more likely to
take his last name or would he take your
last name hmm no i don't i um
i really like my last name yeah we
talked about it i never wanted to change
my last name i think my last name is
really cool it's brandable i think it's
fun
uh
so i never we we talked about it and i'm
like the last name is fun to say right
say it say it out loud cristina pilo
there you go would you add it to your
name no it's too complicated it actually
took out my second last name in in latin
america we have two last names and i
took the second one out
and it did hurt me when i was young yeah
younger i changed my mind
why not but all my male friends do it
and stuff but i didn't comply and didn't
complain or anything just like
i listened to my body it's like dude
it's just a coded thing it's an animal
thing it's an animalistic that's why i
call you mia she has a tattoo and it's a
branded but i don't i don't carry myself
like i own her so if you like that clip
click right here to watch another or if
you want to watch the entire sauce cast
click right here
you